it's the drew barrymore show and it's
halloween 2051 someplace east of the
milky way
please welcome drew barrymore and ross
matthews
thank you so much
for coming here
we're starting drew's news here we go
how are we today is everyone feeling
good
[Applause]
i'm so glad that you guys all showed up
this is such wonderful news i love your
glasses
we all look fantastic i'm so happy to be
here ross hello i'm feeling gorgeous
thank you so much
are we floating in space right elon musk
are you there
drew oh my god your face
what
you've got wrinkles
well yeah i aged naturally oh
how dare you
ross you look good too
um thank you for noticing yeah
you look like one of those
horses that got pulled
well turns out they still got botox in
the future so yay
and i remain filler-free
[Music]
drew i'll take your leftovers thank you
so much yeah i'll take some of my fat
and you can inject it into those lips
okay wow this is so exciting the future
and
our planet
is still here we're all alive and well
isn't that really wonderful
it's the year 2051
and we're thriving yeah but i will say
that i noticed there still are no flying
cars which makes me furious weren't we
promised flying cars in the future yeah
that's what the movies would have let us
think
well it is time for drew's news of the
future where things are looking up first
in future green news
[Music]
we did it
wind and solar power have saved the
planet
change has been reversed thanks to lots
of different alternative sources of
energy plus the invention of the
perfectly cloned meat which reduced
global greenhouse gas emissions
significantly and in a blind i know
[Applause]
in a blind taste test no one could tell
the difference between the fake meat and
the real thing wow well while we're
talking food news scientists have also
created a synthetic carbohydrate that
doesn't make you gain weight yay
i love the future
you can eat all the meaty burgers and
fries you want save the planet and still
fit into your skinny jeans i just ate 12
of them myself and i look great
thank you so much future
this was my fantasy and i've had that
fantasy my whole life i'm so glad we
finally achieved it yeah yeah because
i'm going to motorboat some mac and
cheese as soon as we're done with this
segment
so many amazing things have happened and
yet lego still hasn't invented a soft
block that doesn't hurt when you step on
it you know you think they would have
done that by now oh my god it is the
most painful thing you will ever go
through
also in future political news we are no
longer a two-party system please welcome
the stop arguing and get it done party
that's right
i am a proud member
and here's the best news how much do we
love president leonardo dicaprio oh
thank you
you know i might have stolen a smooch
from the old president back in the
morning really well he's certainly got
my vote if you know what i mean
oh and you know who's serving on our
supreme court these days of course all
that law school paid off it's honorable
justice kimberly kardashian
yep and you can follow all of uh justice
kim's high court antics on her new show
trying to keep up with the kardashians
which also features courtney and travis
married life together while traveling
with machine gun kelly and megan fox
as well as all their kids who have
banded together to open a kardashian
theme park where you can eat salads make
your own lip gloss and float down a lazy
river
it's a wonderful time to be alive it
really is
wait i've got more pop culture news of
the future here's a quick rundown
timothy chalamet just received a
lifetime achievement award for his
pivotal roles including playing johnny
depp in the biopic here's johnny
what a revelation he was yes he has now
absolutely played every role that johnny
depp has ever done including 47 jump
street his latest project to come out
next year
and yes the condos that jeff bezos built
on mars definitely look like
a
i'm just gonna say it
all right it's daytime tv i'm sorry
they look like a
okay
i'm sorry that's what the space race is
all about just a condo measuring contest
oh god you have said that yes
and lastly how do people date in the
future oh i'm glad you asked well
everything now is just virtual you just
put on a helmet and bam you're on a
romantic dinner with anyone in the world
i just wonder how that works after the
third date if you know what i mean
i'm sure they have it figured out
in fact
i'm sure bezos and richard branson and
elon musk have figured out how to reach
you know what i mean
um i'm sorry but does anyone else not
notice that these rockets look like
giant appendages
[Music]
well
i have to say something
i
got really excited about doing this
segment and i'll tell you why i want a
future where things are good pop culture
is thriving people we love are doing
great things we've saved our planet and
we got our crap together
[Music]
[Applause]
and if we may ever be as lucky enough to
be on this show sometime in the future
rossi while you're looking younger and
younger and i'm looking older and older
and the natural stage you know of life
progresses may we live in a world that
actually does have good news
and love and health and a planet that is
beautiful lush and happy
yeah
and i'll be right next to you
rossi
may we be together we clearly go to the
same hair salon and stylist i gotta say
the future looks good the future does
look good
well thank you that's it for drew's news
of the future but ross
i see those yellow doors acting up again
oh no oh my gosh shall we see where it
takes us next let's do it okay
we'll see you right after the break
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you